SPEAKER: Hi, I'd like to
show you a cool new way
to create interactive tutorials
that you can run right
inside the Cloud
Shell environment.
So to start with,
let's take a look
at this GitHub repo under Google
Cloud Platform slash Cloud dash
Shell dash tutorials.
Now this repo contains a file
called tutorial dot md, which
is a markdown specification
of the desired structure
and flow for my tutorial.
Let's look at the underlying
markdown syntax there,
and we see a few things.
There's one top level
header, and this defines
the title of my tutorial.
And then there's a sequence
of second level headers
where each second level header
corresponds to a discrete step
in my tutorial.
The rest of the file contains
the usual markdown syntax
formatting, like highlighting
code snippets and command
lines, and things like that.
There are also a few
special commands,
like this walkthrough
Editor open file.
What this does is it
generates a hyperlink
in the tutorial,
which, when clicked,
will automatically
open that specified
file from the current repo
in the Cloud Shell Editor.
So that's kind of
roughly the syntax of one
of these tutorials.
Let's see it actually
running live.
So we'll go back up
to the top level.
And in the Read
Me for this repo,
I have a hyperlink coded,
which runs that exact file.
So what this does is it
specifies the Cloud Shell URL.
It tells the system
which repo I would
like automatically cloned.
It says I'd like the Cloud
Shell Editor enabled by default.
And the new piece here is this
tutorial equals parameter,
which defines a file in
this repo to be interpreted
as a tutorial in markdown.
So we're directing it
at the tutorial dot md
file we just looked at.
Let's click on that link
and see what happens.
So it's warning me it's
about to auto-clone
a repo into my environment.
It instantiates the
Shell, clones that repo,
starts up the Cloud Shell Editor
with all the files in that repo
as a project, and
it automatically
started my tutorial on the
right-hand side of the screen.
As you can see, I have
my title and my steps
that I can go forward
and backward through.
It highlights some of the
syntax, like this Echo command.
You get an automatic
button to copy that
to the clipboard, which I can
then paste into a Cloud Shell.
So a lot of nice authoring
capabilities there.
And I also have those
special integrated directives
I told you about.
For example, if you
wanted to direct somebody
to click on this
Web Preview button,
rather than kind of direct
them there through imagery
or instructions, you can
generate one of these URL--
or one of these hyperlinks,
which, when clicked,
will automatically spotlight
that portion of the screen.
As you go through to
the end you can even
generate a little widget
that gets feedback
from the user as to what
their experience was
like with the tutorial.
One last thing I
want to show you
is that you can actually
run these tutorials right
from the Shell.
And what I'm going to do
is finish the tutorial,
close it, and then invoke
it again from over here.
All I had to do was run
Cloud Shell, launch tutorial,
minus D for developer
mode, and then
the file in this
current environment
that I want to be the
specification of the tutorial.
And that starts it
just like the hyperlink
did in my previous example.
So this is a nice way
if you're an author
and you want to test and
iterate on a tutorial,
this gives you the ability to
do that right from the console.
That's pretty much it.
I also wanted to point you
to the documentation, which
you can find under
Cloud dot Google dot com
slash Shell slash
docs slash tutorials.
And there you can
find more details
about formatting
your markdown and all
of the different capabilities
that are available,
those special
features I mentioned
for integrating your tutorial
with the console or the Cloud
Shell environment.
So that's it.
I hope you enjoyed that.
I hope this gave you a sense for
some of the powerful things you
can do in authoring these
tutorials in the Google Cloud
environment.
Thanks.